こんにちははじめしゃちょーです
ハッピーハロウィーン
[音楽]
[拍手]
というわけで皆さんハロウィンですよ
いかがお過ごしでしょうか
僕は渋谷ハロウィンに行こうと思ったん
ですけども
案の定やめておきました今年のハロウィン
何をしようかと言いますと最近ですね
僕の後輩のサーブという男がですね
一人暮らしを始めたみたいなんですよ
祝いたいというわけで今日の動画は
いたってシンプルです
後輩の家を犯していっぱいにしてみた
大
迷惑
いや大迷惑なわけじゃないですけど嬉しい
ですよ普通に一応後輩の家間取りとか調べ
ないとどれくらいのお菓子パーティーか
わからないので下見してきましたようこそ
我が家ですはいでもそんななんか
普通にいいお家だけどね
はいここはもうメインの部屋で
[音楽]
はい
欲しいものはちょっと書き出します
自分の
自分の欲しいもの
いや違いますちょっと
ほら
ほらこれ返して
[拍手]
[音楽]
何があるだろう
可愛かったのけどパッと見そんな
大丈夫そうねだいたい普通によくあるこう
なんか1Kって言うんですかね普通の
一人暮らしの男の子のお部屋みたいな感じ
ででまだ引っ越したばっかりなので部屋の
ものもかなり少なかったので絶好のお菓子
チャンススイートショータイムSee
younexttime引っ越したての今
だったら絶対いい感じに犯して埋め尽くせ
そうなスペースのお部屋があったので今日
は後輩の部屋をお菓子で埋め尽くしたいと
思います
僕確認ですね車の中を置かせていっぱいに
したことがあったんですけどもなんとなく
どれぐらいの金額感でお部屋がいっぱいに
なるかとわかるんですよ
ざっくりとこれくらいあればいけるかなっ
ていうぐらいのお金全部しました
30万円分ね30万円準備しましたこれ
ぐらいあれば多分お菓子にもよるんです
けども1人暮らしの男の部屋ぐらいはお
菓子でいっぱいにできるんじゃないかと
思って今から分岐に行っておかしく買って
いきたいと思います車でドンキー行くんで
どれくらいお菓子積み込めるかわかんない
んですけどもとりあえずおかし買っていき
たいと思いますではいこう
[音楽]
ハロウィンのお菓子を買いに行くよ車で
行くよさあ皆さん見てくださいどんぐりし
ましたお金準備したよこんな感じまで行く
ぞ
1時間後おるはじめさんすごい量買って
ないですかあれ大丈夫ですか
助けても運べないよこんなに分かっちゃっ
たけど大丈夫かなこれ10万円ってこれ
ぐらい買っちゃってるのさあ車につきまし
た
早速入れていこうと思います
[音楽]
はいいっぱいあっ疲れたもう年玉私も
じゃあこれはとはさあ早速ターゲットに
つきましたこのギア俺
あれなんか今
物落としてなかった
えっ
ちゃんこれいますねこの家大丈夫
怖い痛いターゲットの家に着きましたうわ
なんだかちょっと小汚いですねこんな
ところに食べかけもあるジャスミッキー
こんなところで飲みかけて蓋を開けっ放し
で止めるなさあ早速部屋をちょっとだけ
片付けて色々ポイってこう片付けて広くし
たところにあの今買ってきたあの行きます
はい片付けましためんどくさいので動画
カットしましたけど見てくださいこの広々
とした部屋まあだいたい1Kのマンション
はこれぐらいだと思います
早速ここに買ってきたのを入れるよ
ポンポンポンチョンチョンチョン
トントンはいできましたこれが10枚分の
お菓子ですね見てくれ
実際の僕の身長186cmのところでどれ
くらいの大きさの差があるんですね早速
これを開けてあのお菓子を中あの行きます
行きますこれ
結構大きいからあのサイズ感でかいので
場所取れるかなって勝手に言いました
ドンキは安いねやっぱり
安値の電動
ドロドロドロさあ続いてはカ
俺バニラしか興味ないからいつもチョコ
だけ残っててよくあの弟に無理やり食わせ
てたドロドロドロドロさあ続いてはキット
カットですねあのこれも結構場所取る重い
ドロドロえファイナミに深みショコラ期間
限定なのでおいしそう
ツマミ食いパクリ
うーん
72点
ドロドロドロドロドロドロドロはい
キノコの止めたたけのこの山菜
オリオンの友達キャベツ太郎もかなり
大きくてこれはあの大きく顔と比べても4
つ買っちゃったら4つ
ええとピザポテトも
ピザポテトも俺の中では結構好きなとこ
カプリコのミニのやつですけどもこれも
結構場所取るから大きいのでたくさんあり
ました
えっとこれねムーンライトチャレンジで
ラウンド1にそろそろ行きたい季節になっ
てきましたえーたくさん買ってみましたえ
うまい棒のとっても大きいやつもたくさん
えっと私の最近の一応こちら
昨夜はチョコ次郎これはドロドロドロもう
全部回収できてしまいましたええとみんな
に面白くないポイ
目覚めなさいはいというわけでようやく音
が飛べてないことに気づきました
俺が好きなお菓子はこれがちょっと待って
本当どうしようマジでどうしよう
はいというわけで僕が好きなお菓子
シリーズはまあこんな感じですね
こんな感じでまあ好きなの置けたんで
残りはドンキーになるものを全種類買う
みたいな方向でもういろんなお菓子を
片っ端から買ってきましたこれ紹介すると
普通に1日終わっちゃうのでとりあえず
どんどん出していこうと思います
いや
すごいぞま10万円でこんな感じでした
すげえ量だよこれもうだいたい部屋の7割
ぐらいに床が埋まったなって感じです
10万円で
なんだ10万円ですまだ10万円なんです
よこっからさらに20万円30万円分のお
菓子入れていくんですけどもドンキのお
菓子はほぼ買ったんであとはまた買って
ないお菓子そしてなんかポテトとかって
結構大きいのでボリュームがある箇所買い
まくってどんどんかさ増しして最終的には
この部屋を全てお菓子で満帆にしたいと
思いますではさらに10万円分買ってき
ます
20万円分
起きました
これやばいっすねこれはやばいもう
正直なんか羨ましいとかの次元を超えて
申し訳ないまで来てますでもそれが
ハロウィンというわけでこれで今20万円
分なのであと10万円分くるんですけども
もうここからはかさ増し作戦ですいかに
部屋が犯す埋まってるか見せるためにもう
大きなポテトの袋とかもうとりあえず内容
量が大きいものを開幕さらに
持って持って盛りまくりたいと思います
頑張ります
[音楽]
はいというわけで
後輩の部屋が全部お風になりました
こんな感じになってしまいました
このお菓子のバリエーションもうグミとか
もチョコもう
ほとんどのお菓子を基本的に全種類のお
菓子は買わせていただきましたこの
ラインナ
作山チョコ次郎なくなっちゃった
[音楽]
あいましたいました皆さん奇跡的にその
ポッキーの島から出てますチョコ次郎
[音楽]
終わりいや悪いじゃねえんだいいことし
てるんですよハッピーハロウィンという
ことでおめでとうございます無事にま
30万円ぐらいやったら結構ほぼぼかすに
なることができましたね
えー
かさ増ししてあります特にダンボール入れ
てちょっとだけ山になるようにしてあるん
ですけどもまそれがなくても間違いなく
全部おかしいで埋まっています後輩のお
うちですね30万円分買いました
合計何点だったかてかレシートやばい
本当に見たことないような長さになって
ます
合計ですね1751
点で30万円分のお菓子になりましたここ
17501個のお菓子があります
すごいもうすぐこのお部屋の後輩が帰って
くるんでまあちょっと部屋を暗くしといて
帰ってきたらパッと明かりをつけて明かり
をこう見た瞬間お菓子を目の前にしてもう
チャンスを喜ぶことでしょう
間違いない
結構お金に困ってる後輩出していつもお金
ないんすよみたいな話をしてたんでもう
ハロウィンということでもうはじめしゃ
ちょーからのトーク台プレゼントでござい
ますはいというわけでそろそろターゲット
が帰ってきますまあそもそもこうやって人
がいる時点で怖いと思うんですけれども
奥に進むとこちらお菓子の山です
[音楽]
電気
つける前に言うな
[音楽]
ハッピーハロウィン
どうですか
やば電気をつける前にお前やばってった
なあ
うーん
素人らしくて
嫌いじゃないぜ
ハロウィンということであなたの心境祝い
お家をお菓子だらけにしてみましたー
すごいおめでとうございますどうですか今
の率直な気持ちは
[音楽]
あ
嬉しいということでよかったです本当に
少し全部で30万円分ですね
[音楽]
確かに
すげーでもちょっと夢が叶った気分ですね
ありがとう
[音楽]
ございます
実際いる
いらないです